so after months and months of leading
players on a wild goose chase Sombra has
finally been released for everyone to
play and we're here to give you guys a
quick rundown of her abilities and how
she fits into the current state of
overwatch first up on her ability list
is her machine pistol now this is not a
very strong gun by any means but it's a
very fast one it's good at close range
and it holds 60 bullets so you might not
have the strongest firepower out there
but you've got a lot of it and much like
tracer you're going to be running around
pestering people getting in getting out
putting damage on people when it needs
to be and the way for her to get in is
with her through optic camo which turns
her invisible and boosts for speed so he
can get behind enemy lines really really
quickly you can use it to hide from
people or as just a quick burst of speed
whenever you need it but be careful
because if anyone shoots you you'll drop
out of the camo immediately so heroes
like Winston or Deva shooting around
randomly if they know you're there can
be a huge threat to you
so if you do run into a little bit of
trouble she does have another ability
her translocator now this is a beacon
that you can either toss on the ground
or even in the air and afterwards you'll
have 15 seconds to warp back to it until
it disappears so if you place it in your
health pack and run to a little bit of
trouble you can warp out and heal
instantly or you can use it to say throw
over a wall to escape people chasing you
but perhaps her most useful move is her
hack now this is the ability that people
have been speculating about for months
and months and we are wondering what
hacking another player actually entails
well now that she's finally out we know
so her hack ability is a mid-range
channel move where you hold it for a
couple seconds and they'll get a debuff
at the end of it and hack does a number
of things first you can hack a health
pack to make it regen quicker but also
make it inaccessible to enemies so when
your health pack you hack is your team's
to keep and there is no limit to how
many health packs you can hack as long
as you keep refreshing it after 60
seconds and you can also hacked enemy
heroes disabling all of their special
abilities includes but is not limited to
Genji's reflect soldiers sprint and even
Torbjorn turrets become inactive so if
you're looking to lock someone down who
you know is going to run away you just
hack them
now it doesn't shut down every ability
things like Zarya shield or some bolts
will still stay active even after you
hack them but it's really really
effective at keeping them from fighting
back and if they do manage to get away
from you this is where sombras
opportunist ability comes into play it
allows her to see enemy heroes through
walls if they have less than 50% health
it's really useful and it's a great way
to keep eyes on whoever ran away from
you
so you can find them hack them and
finish them off
and if you're looking to hack multiple
people well look no further than Somers
ultimate her EMP now her EMP unleashes a
huge bubble of electromagnetic energy
and it hacks everyone within a very
large radius so what you want to do with
it is get behind the enemy lines with
their camo unleash the EMP and then
translocate back leaving the whole team
kind of discombobulated but
communication is the key with this
because your team needs to know when
you're going to EMP so they can take
advantage of the enemy team not having
shields up or being able to use any of
their abilities so if you're looking to
play Sombra I would advise to you to
stay hidden because once you're spotted
camo isn't going to do anything to
escape the translocator and hacked
health pack combo is a pretty good thing
to fall back on but I think if you're in
a bind
I would use a translocator to confuse
the enemy you would throw it behind them
teleport and then immediately camo away
with sambar is all about staying unseen
and hacking only when necessary and if
you're trying to figure out what
matchups to press and which ones to
avoid I would say to go after people who
are already at low health now this is a
given for any damage dealer but
especially for sambar since she can take
away other people's abilities other
heroes with escape abilities those are
the ones that you want to hack and
either pursue them or let your team
finish them off otherwise you're going
to have a lot of freedom to attack
whomever you want mostly because of the
translocator but I would say watch out
for tanks because you know Winston's and
divas are going to ruin your day if they
know you're around but if you stay
steadfast and strong you'll have a fuel
day.if will train the enemy team and
hacking everything in sight
moreover watch coverage visit
gamespot.com
or check out the YouTube playlist to see
our guys for the other 23 heroes